hello everyone wow intro
it's called great great cool
i'm a lot of a video game writer that
look at me pointing it's mike bithell it
kind of feels
weird it feels like it should be a
rectangular
yeah just right here very strange uh
yeah we're in vegas for dice
you got in on sunday been too long guys
i've been too long
is it like interstellar where it's been
an hour for us but you've been here for
seven years it's like yeah it's it's
vegas is not somewhere to linger i mean
it's totally angry second sorry i
strongly agree it is it is very cool for
two days and then awful ever after that
yeah so i'm definitely at that likes
yeah like a day was it what even our
days anymore it's like four or five yeah
yeah i've never i've never i've been a
dice a handful of times i've never come
that early it's always like because i
got here yesterday night me too are you
yeah okay yeah
no i got it at midnight actually i drove
because i currently don't have a
passport
um which was fine it's very black out
there but do you have a driver's license
does that not count
no because it's australian so i can get
on planes with australian possible you
can't get on your driver's license is an
australian driver's license yes which
you're allowed to use i didn't know that
yeah because it counts as an
international license so um i can use it
as a driver's license
but even after all this time that you've
been in the us you didn't have to get a
new license never for anything um and i
won't have to that's all we're gonna
talk about today yeah this is a license
welcome
we're in person for the first time it's
episode 95 i'm pretty sure uh we're
talking about licenses this is the
content people come in i was gonna ask
you guys so in terms of like your
meetings like are you coming in and
doing like back to back-to-back meetings
for those like couple days you're here
or is it much more kind of fleeting for
you i rejected all of that you reject
everything a lot of people asked me for
meetings and i said i don't have time
i'm still doing my day job just here
yeah i'm here for the awards because i'm
presenting awards and then you sat on
your laptop for the rest of the thing
yeah yeah so i'm actually just in here
working um well i guess as well you
don't have as many kind of like like
austin obviously has to find like people
to work with and do something i have to
find like partners on all levels
like you've got less of a need i guess i
have no need for meetings in the
meetings that people usually want to
have with me are then talking to me as
an influencer which i have no interest
in having meetings about so it's a lot
of people being like yeah what could we
do to get you to stream this and i'm
like i don't have any interest in
talking about this like
i i email the person on my twitter so i
i don't tend to take them because it's
usually that they're like followers
money and it's not interesting where's
that if i were to take meetings with
other writers or something that would be
super cool i
asked is that anything do writers do
that they're writing
but like is that because i had i asked
specifically because literally had
breakfast with a game designer
um who
was saying how
this has reminded him how rarely he
talks to other designers and how he's
been loving it he's like see someone in
the hallway he was like i shared an
elevator with the game director on
return and i was like dude i have so
many questions
with that guy he just lives in the
elevator
does he have a t-shirt saying ask me
about return actually living
which i'm very excited about because
like i want to ask her a lot of
questions but also like how did you do
this but also how did you do it as a
woman like i want to talk to her about
it so bad so i'm
seeing amy hennig there but yeah dice i
tend to just like do the same thing like
just pass somebody in a hallway and say
hi and then keep moving um
but i also
when i was pressed was when i was first
coming to nice and i was going to a lot
of the panels and they're super
interesting
yeah they're great here especially
especially because it's one track as
well so everyone's seen the exact same
so you actually have conversations with
those with people who've been there
you're right it's a mic problem
there's no mic
no i'm just checking i'm just checking
to make sure our levels are okay i can't
resist despite the fact that it's not
glorious to watch i'm just checking for
sure it's definitely a component of
these things that you're not it's not
like every meeting or like sit down you
have is specifically like trying to get
work so like yeah writers hanging out i
mean yeah i bet you you meet with some
like composers and stuff just hanging
out austin shoot the [ __ ] right actually
funny enough sorry i'm realizing i don't
like that placement um it's the first
time i've ever used this one but i
haven't i have one like it better right
yeah yeah this is the newer model of the
one that i have that's like the g that's
i associate that specific microphone
like journalism yeah it's like a
journalist
they're so useless they're good for
field recording
uh not bad under a thousand but i can't
remember how far under it's definitely
that's still pretty expensive pretty
expensive it's a pretty big range though
check your privilege austin
well but microphones can be 25 000
you know so oh yeah seriously
oh yeah you go to a place like abbey
road and you know they open up their
closet of the mics that they're like
deploying for an orchestra session and
you're talking about hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of mics
oh yeah
the cool thing as total trivia about
that is on
the movie the king's speech you know
that his nemesis is the microphone uh he
can't get over his stammer right that's
kind of the premise of that film it's so
good i loved it
did you like is that as a british person
is that one of those that like irks it
like sets off your radar of like this is
about us i don't like it that's a super
it's like the least offensive movie ever
right like it's just an absolutely in
terms of like it's it's just so likeable
and i i loved it
i didn't see it as
milk toast in that way though like it's
it was sort of
avoiding anything tricky it just told
and interesting i feel like you were
about to say a piece of trigger about
the movie we got caught up in
criticizing the waves
yeah no so the whole thing was that
because they're the royal family yeah um
once microphone technology became a
thing at the beginning of the 20th
century they of course made a special
like here's the king's mic here's the
queen's mic and here's like churchill's
mic
and they had ones that were handmade for
them alone and so they had to make a
replica of they couldn't find
uh the the king um
uh the actual king's mic so they but
they knew what it looked like so they
they made a replica of it for the movie
and then they went to record the score
um at abbey road and they realized that
mike was in the storage at abbey road so
they recorded the orchestra with the
actual
real kings mic
that's the movie that they couldn't find
when actually shooting the movie it was
the story of the composer how is that
something that you just have laying
around it's abbey road like yeah
everything's a legend
yeah it's literally
there's nothing in that building that
isn't somehow like oh yeah that's the
tape deck that paul mccartney you
know the building yeah
it's not small it has it's funny it's
the first recording studio ever built um
it was it was commissioned by sir edward
elgar
um and
the
meaning it like recordings had already
been happening it's the first time they
built a building that sold purpose was
for recording because they would use
like a church or whatever before that
but even then it's still over 100 years
ago
music churches
yeah like very acoustically resonant
spaces you know like to record the
churches were bad for acoustics no super
lush i mean it's bad if you want to hear
super pristine details because
everything gets so washed out yeah but
you know there's a reason why it sounds
really beautiful when the choir sings
yeah the gravitas of the space is is
very immediate
so abby road studio one is the scoring
stage where you could fit a huge
orchestra and i believe despite the fact
that it was literally the first ever
made it's still the largest i think you
can fit because like john williams did
the star wars films there hey check your
big go
there's the there's a footage of him
doing um like duel of the fates in that
room and that's like a hundred piece
orchestra and probably 40 voice choir
all performing together simultaneously
it's an unbelievable amount of musicians
that can fit in that room
um and and comfortable like it's not
exploding and
um so and that's the big room studio two
is the small one that's the beatles room
that's like where it's not small small
but it you can't fit more than maybe 30
musicians or like a band that's kind of
properly yeah and then there's also
smaller there's a studio i think it's
studio three or they have a different
name for it but there's also some mixing
rooms where it's basically just a desk
and speakers and you go in there to mix
and master and things like that
and then random closets full of like
history you know and that's super cool
so it's not a small building but it's
it's also deceptively you roll up to it
and if it didn't have a sign on the
front there's nothing about it that
would make you go oh that's that and
then you realize like oh that and
there's the crosswalk like
it's all very nondescript if if you
would if it weren't for the fact that
there's always tourists there taking
photos in that like putting their life
at risk but they're only taking photos
of the crosswalk yeah most people
probably don't care about
this building itself
the exterior of the building i mean
they're intrinsically connected to each
other obviously because that crosswalk
being the cover of the album was what
and the album was there like always a
massive queue to the
probably
there's always people it's whether it's
a big giant gathering but i had a friend
who happened to be recording at abbey
road just by coincidence on the 50th
anniversary of the day that photo was
taken
so he went and stepped outside and it
was like
a zombie movie i mean it was just
thousands of people like the world war z
you know forming if you were america
someone would be charging people to take
photos oh yeah no if it was america
there'd be like five replicas down the
street yeah that crosswalk probably
would be safer
i always ask the the tabbies and stuff
you know is this it must be stressful to
drive around here because you just know
there's gonna be people stepping
unexpectedly out into the road thank you
yeah he was like oh it's a no it's not
just the people crossing the crosswalk
it's the people taking photos of the
people crossing across the world in the
middle of the road next to the crosstalk
yeah
yeah it is it is fortunately not the
busiest area
um
you know relative to other neighborhoods
in london like if you go first thing in
the morning rush hour traffic there's
people passing through yeah but then
once that kind of dies down there's
definitely windows where you can because
i've done it of course shamelessly where
you got to run into the middle and kind
of like pose and then someone has to go
and position themselves also in the
street to take your photo but it's like
oh there's a car a mile down the road
yeah
yeah but not that day
really i'm covering all the topics
people want to hear this is this is the
most like in-depth
and then you realize when you see them
how nonchalant yeah and nothing they
actually
look it's kind of like the equivalent of
when you like if you've ever met i feel
that way about troy i was just gonna say
that's so funny i literally
just said there's like it's always there
it was i said that's to go that's how i
felt when i first met troy god damn it
this is all it says
this is the classic
in this case he actually is taller than
he is i always forget how tall you are
like it's always whenever i see you i'm
like
yeah people yeah
this podcast but even though i know you
well and i've seen you several times
it's still a surprise every time i am
told for a woman obviously we were
talking to maggie robertson who plays uh
lady dean resident well she's much
taller she's eight feet high a whole
eight foot she's very tall i think she's
six three no i think it's just six even
but she just really but she's also like
one of those people that some people are
like small framed and they just seem
like reeds you know so they don't seem
tall whereas some people i believe
maggie is very regal
like
exactly she's not she doesn't look
flimsy you know she's she's like she has
gravitas which is why
she said they were so excited when she
because she we just finished doing a
podcast together like five seconds
before
the the
podcast the game makers notebook
unacceptable you have been a guest on
that so yeah but not with you was that
before you are you like the regular host
on that now no
robin is the talk to people like you
guest host you know the lucas popes and
the show like fitness pretentious people
yeah
the mics
and uh and then at one point they said
you know it'd be cool to have composers
on this show would you be our guest host
to talk shop composers but then we did
one with troy and the idea was maybe
troy can be
now interviewing fellow actors but then
it was just like
got busy or whatever so they just hit me
up and said hey
since three years ago you did one with
troy you want to do one with maggie
and i was like dude yeah and uh it was
awesome but she was talking about how
you know auditioning as an actor and
being over six feet tall as a woman
closed a lot of doors and then like blew
this one open you know
they immediately saw her and were like
oh hell yes she has to hold herself
differently normally anyway yeah she
presumably she does the performance yeah
capture as well yeah she again she had
never done she had moved to la like two
months earlier than this from new york i
think she said right uh from london
technically but she moved around a lot
actually i think and so she
yeah she said that it was like on some
audition website of just you know like
she said it seemed like a little indie
game or something she had no impression
they always play it down she just got
embraced
so hard by the game's community it's
it's been wild like i don't know if i've
ever seen anything like that with any
character before that's really cool i
told her i said i i said i saw
cosplayers of that character before i
saw the trailer no way like i said it
seemed like there were cosplayers within
24 hours yeah and and i hadn't caught
the trailer yet and so i i it was like
oh that in the trailer oh i i recognized
them from so-and-so's instagram like
it's so weird it was i said i've never
seen something get picked up that fast
she's got so much love it's so cool it's
like such a positive way for someone to
be introduced to video games like just
the whole community was like we love you
like it's very very cool that's cool
yeah she's awesome
yeah
she could feel her very palpable
appreciation of that that
it wasn't oh you're this outsider and
like good for you you did the thing
move along yeah we've kind of got our
crew yeah um it's been very much the
opposite which is how i said look i
always felt that way i felt so at home
in the industry instantly even though i
was entering for flow which
nobody knew what to make of that but
even still it was kind of like oh cool
you know you you guys are like these
interesting weirdos like tgc you know
and
um it always felt so welcoming but
that's always that always feels like
that's part of it like i had it last
night i was i was sat down talking to a
guy and realized like a few minutes and
he was the director of forgotten city
and just kind of talking to him and it's
like he's been yeah
um that game is really cool it was
really cool but it's that thing of like
i feel like every year there's like an
indie or you know new developers made
something really cool that just kind of
comes in and just like everyone kind of
you know throws her arms around them and
her works and welcomes them into the
group it's really nice it's a really
nice aspect of the community for sure on
the dev side i mean yeah i would say
that i agree in terms of the games
industry itself but starting out in
media i like my experience is the direct
opposite really well
not from media but from the community it
could be more different to manny that
everyone like oh you mean the audience
yeah oh okay like it was terrible when i
started out it's going a lot better but
like when i started out it was like it
wasn't even like i disagree with your
opinion it was like you don't really
play video games it's [ __ ] terrible i
mean that's a it's an old meme
yes such a weird
i've never understood that i've never
understood the like
let's say you were to go you got me
what has been like
what have they proven or what have they
achieved like like what i've never it's
not about winning an argument austin
you're giving way more respectively
so many other things that i could do
that would be easier and would make more
money yeah than trying to make it as a
games journalist when i started out and
also you would just have to read
anything i'd read written or anything i
ever said and be like oh yeah she did
especially you because you're you're
you're kind of extremely in the other
direction you play [ __ ] everything
yeah i feel like i tend to play more
games than most people who work in game
dev from my perspective and also from
the media side
um oh yeah it doesn't happen anymore
like i said it was just when i started
out yeah it's gotten way better it's
definitely more welcoming now and uh
definitely like joining dev was
entirely just like dms from people being
like this is awesome
let's talk about it if you have any
questions ask me like people are very
welcoming how does that show people
living their dreams
like people who you know doing what they
love yeah i mean there's obviously you
know bad days and bad stuff in the
industry but like i think the the
baseline is pretty important individual
human yeah for the most part
how is it because this
like um when we all saw each other at
the last dice which was basically the
last dice before this one yeah i mean
the online stuff to me doesn't really
count yeah um down in the bar yeah i
remember in another hotel right yeah we
were i had somewhere
yeah i was really lost and i was like
where's the escalator in the thing yeah
claudia was like
you know we were in a different hotel
yeah it was the first time
no we used to be at the domino then it
moved to the re
got
aria yeah
also apparently this is the biggest ever
too really yeah he was like so many
people i think are so starved for stuff
because i thought it would be the
opposite i thought we're gonna show up
and it's gonna be like us and three
other people yeah and just you know just
between
you know people out of the rhythm of it
and or anxious about kind of
cracking that seal for the first time
and that sort of thing and
and uh he was like yeah no we're like 20
past our record wow the tenants we've
ever had like it's
great but it still feels nice and small
that's what i like about it it feels
like an intimate event you actually have
a chance of seeing everyone you want to
see
yeah yeah so i there are like two parts
in my head of conversations i really
want to talk about the categories thing
but then i also wanted to be like uh for
the oscars but i also wanted to
mike so from from your perspective what
what is dice for you like what is the
purpose of it in a way that you wouldn't
spoil anything or you could be
informative to
people in your position to come to an
event like this what do you do here i'm
presenting an award yeah that's why i'm
here austin's podcasting i'm in the
awards too you're also in the awards
podcast impresario you're doing like
three or four podcasts
yeah
ridiculously yeah yeah well in the short
version is that i i
fundamentally i mean what you said
before about how it's kind of like
there's a certain element of being a
freelancer where you're kind of
you know
you're sort of like a hunter uh
you know scouting the horizon but the
truth is i'm very lucky that that part
of my career
seems to be mostly
behind me people come to you obviously
now i i'm not i'm not lacking for for
opportunities and like the bills are
paid food has food's in the fridge and
and and
you know i've got a bit of runaway yeah
um
so it becomes
overwhelmingly a social thing i just
come because i love the people in this
industry i'm really inspired by hanging
out with them and talking to them and
and like i had i had i had breakfast
this morning with a guy
who had approached me to score his game
potentially he was talking to a few
folks and then he went with someone else
but we just really got along and i was
like and he texted me and goes hey we've
never actually met in person because
that went down we connected with the
first time during the pandemic so he was
like
you know hey we're both going to do this
let's finally like hang out for real for
you so we had this like an amazing
wonderful time and and this is one where
explicitly he's not looking for somebody
he found someone and he even found
someone over me like i was an option so
did you make him the whole breakfast no
that was the thing like what's your next
project yeah exactly when are you going
to get that stupid thing done and move
on to a real game
um
yeah i know it was one of those you
enjoyed the big leagues yeah
yeah this must be really thrilling to
you to like
no it was it just that was the thing it
was very genuinely like
um
validation that it is so much about the
people and i don't need someone to offer
me a job to like really enjoy their
company and i think a lot of composers
in particular get really twisted up in
that i'm always trying to put that
message out there of like make friends
some subset of your friends will be
potential work opportunities but don't
don't look for people as a way to get
work and then maybe become friends with
it well that's the thing i just oppose
networking no me too but like what
you're saying is networking that's a
healthier version it's what it should be
whenever anyone asks me about networking
is like yes i know a lot of people in
the games industry i never tried to i
just went to stuff and drank with people
and ate with people and that's it like
there was never any intent i never gave
out a business card i never did anything
and 99 of them will never be anything
other than someone you hung out with and
had a drink with and that's and that's
great like there's not a weird subtext
of oh i wanted to be hanging out with
you but i realize you're not really it's
obvious when people do that too like you
can feel it if somebody does it to you
that you're like okay
oh you can read it immediately yeah i i
have it's the shifty eyes i've seen who
else is in yeah they're working out
they're working out your hierarchical
place and yeah no it's it's immediately
the most off-putting thing um yeah so
from my experience it's like i would say
like fifty percent exactly what you just
said in terms of like it's just i can't
friends it's yeah
[Laughter]
but it is like it's like been two years
and i'm saying this i'm saying someone
earlier like literally i was talking i
was talking to a
friend uh someone i really confided in
someone i really care about who i only
ever see in personal events yeah and
like so actually being an event and
seeing seeing him even if it's only like
for like a few hours on one of the days
it's a big deal and there's i've got a
number of friends like that and it means
a lot
then on top of that for me um because i
own a game studio i have just
an enormous number of people i'm
currently working with i need to talk to
and check in with you you're also hiring
right now right yeah but i'm not hiring
here because to be honest like with dice
dice is predominantly uh here
it's and bosses ultimately like people
who are already yeah yeah i'm not going
to recruit like uh i'm going to be able
to
recruit many workers here because
outside of freelancers yeah it's there's
not you're you're average kind of person
on a team unless they're up for an award
that's kind of the the one that breaks
it um they're not here so no for me
generally i'm talking to either people
we're currently working with and that
can be that can be publishers that can
be platform and it is publishers and
platform holders predominantly is some
of that stuff just like we're mostly
having conversations over zoom or
whatever right now should we catch up in
person it's it's yeah well it's it's
also just like a human thing it's what
austin says kind of scales to
corporations as well it's like trying to
give it like an example like um so like
i have obviously relationships with all
of the major major platform holders but
like hanging out socially with them is
like something that means something and
it's those connections those human
connections it's i don't think this is
something that's very easy as like a
member of the audience to kind of see
games companies as these kind of
mythical kind of corporations but it's
like no it's it's it's good to meet up
and hang out and ultimately most of
these are human relationships and also
humans move between those companies so
it's like i'll literally have had a had
a meeting which was actually just
grabbing a coffee with like someone the
other day who's
been at two of the three major platforms
over the years and yes we were talking
about the wonders of xbox on this
conversation but you know a few years
ago we talked about the ones like it's
fine like it's it's that there's this
there's that kind of thing so so there's
maintaining the relationships and just
kind of chatting to people we are
working with currently and having that
human connection yeah
the big the big one as well with events
like this is the is happenstance it's
just like running into people you've
never met before i literally this
morning
like yesterday
i'm gonna have to leave about 70 details
of this story yesterday like got an
email from someone um had a publisher
with a lot of like interesting ip saying
hey we'd love to we'd love to talk to
you and then today we met with that
person offhandedly said oh do you have
the ip of do you you own blah right
and he's like i mean he's i'm like you
must be making something with why he's
like nah no we're waiting for the right
idea and i literally just pitched him
like a 10 minute pitch like what i would
do without be in the room and like i
would never have gone that way terribly
it went terribly and obviously it'll
never happen no uh to be honest
unfortunately i'm you know super busy on
other things well fortunately i'm too
busy on other things but like the um but
like those kind of opportunities
you can't casually send an email
bitching like a pup but this was just
he'd seen me in a corridor and liked one
of my games when i have a chat and it
leads somewhere yeah and that that has
happened so many times i mean that's
that's how i've
found loads of i mean that's how i met
youtube right it was probably at some
conference we met on a beach in croatia
we met on the beach
we met in the beach
basically this scene what the [ __ ] is
this that's that's me
we had that put up for the podcast
so that's a brilliant example of like me
and austin we i think we've like tweeted
each other dm'd a bit yeah i think it
was
like mutual
awareness and kind of chat but then yeah
we were at there's a games conference in
croatia called um uh reboot developed
right
now and we just realized we were in the
in the same city so it's like hey i'll
meet you on the i'll meet you outside
that bar that's so romantic you guys
yeah oh we've been together
um
but that's but that's yeah that's a big
part of it and and then the other thing
is i met you at gdc i'm awesome here so
yeah it's how it works podcast it's
those kind of things magic happens
it's funny because it's it's true hi
like i i i forget that the birth of this
was actually that comic-con panel true
yeah yeah and it was you messaging us
afterward to go that was cool we should
do it again yeah it was like 95 times
this is people who really like talking
to each other we should do this yeah it
was it was a it was a it was a like a i
think it was like a good panel but there
was an excellent dinner after that it
wasn't really
we realized like five hours of
conversation later that we actually
that food was amazing i
who did pick that i don't know
that could have been one of the movie
people or something i don't know yeah
maybe yeah it was great is that the one
we had to walk up the stairs yeah yeah
it was like a vegan place right yeah
yeah yeah because i well that's the
thing is is if you mention ever to like
a partner that you're a vegetarian um
they'll only take you to vegan
restaurants forever forever i know every
vegan restaurant in l.a just from
dropping this
they're so amazing yeah there's some
amazing places but like yeah so i um so
yeah but that's the thing isn't it those
kind of connections can't really happen
online or don't organically usually have
long line yeah especially right now
because with with the pandemic meaning
that people who
already
like now everybody lives on zoom so much
that
um i'll have meetings with someone if
it's a casual just text someone realize
i haven't talked to them in like 12
months and i just think
i don't like going that long without
just saying hi and catching up so text
them hey are you free yeah let's talk
tuesday we get on and then it's like we
start talking at 10 a.m and then at 10
27 they're like well so i gotta roll
into my next thing it's pretty precisely
right now and it's like the life gets
super regimented on zero there's no
we've talked about it it's a pro it's a
real thing we've kind of acknowledged
that our company and are trying to work
on but there's no casual conversation if
you look at like how um how like uh i
think pixar's the one that's famous for
it like pixar deliberately is laid out
to force people to walk past each
other's desks right and have
conversations and you see that a lot in
like in like well-designed kind of
corporate spaces like encouraging
accidental meetings or like valves and
valves desks are like all in wheels or
something
because i started working in triple a
during a pandemic yeah
you never have an accidental
conversation no you really can't yeah
it's tough it's it's a thing that i feel
like i've missed a lot of like insight
into how different departments work and
just getting to like i so badly want
that experience of being able to walk
behind somebody's desk and be like what
are you doing right now well you'll get
that are they gonna are they opening up
no comment sorry of course yeah we're on
the podcast
i genuinely like i swear for like 50 of
the podcast's history i've been unaware
that we're recording the podcast
all the time i always forget which i
mean it means it's candid yeah um
yeah i feel like do you
so i guess the consensus would be that
we recommend people come to things like
dice or gdc if they i i would the
industry i would the thing i think pax
is really good there's obviously
challenges like financially and travel
what i would suggest and encourage is
like if you're in if you want to be in
the games industry like finding your
local thing initially like because you
know obviously from americans this is uh
you know some way you know do a road
trip to vegas and drop by and and also
you don't necessarily have to like have
a pass to these things you can just be
in town at the same time
um i mean the gc
badges
yeah you could just be in san francisco
that week stupidly expensive but like if
you're if you're in like if you want to
show up at the hotel yeah a lot of folks
that do that totally be around i've done
it i've done it several times i think
i've done it at every single conference
at some point i've gone without uh
without passing i should have passed the
dice i mean i have one for the awards
obviously but i don't actually have a
pass i think i could probably
message someone and get one you'd be
allowed now because you're no longer
pressed because they're not allowed you
wouldn't have been able to get into like
the round because the round tables are
close to press but now you're dead you
feel louder
and they're really good and then you
know you you think i don't have to be
like
but like the yeah no finding local if
you're international like so for me like
coming to uh dicer at uc that's like
obviously expensive because the flights
and everything like if you're
international like there's
there's good game events in most kind of
parts of the world like and i would i
would encourage people to start there
like find where your local kind of
hangout is because also those local uh
events will then usually like bring in a
few gifts and i think all three of us
probably at some point have been like
you i know you do a lot of it i do i do
as well like going to like a smaller
event in you know somewhere in europe
and you know it might be that i've been
invited to those but it never works with
my schedule yeah i can never i'd love to
be able to go um they're fun like those
little local communities
but never you need to travel
internationally and have time off work
and i can never do that well now though
so many of those things do
they do it through zoom like i've done a
lot of things out and
no it's true i guess i just specifically
mean if if someone has organized a thing
in you know like i just recently it was
it was like a university in florida i
want to say
but it was like
a small group just they just they were
putting together a thing like you're
talking about on their end
they were taking your advice without
knowing it and and then just emailed me
and said would you be willing to come
come on a zoom call like we'll all be in
a room together yeah so
you know
it's a it's a slightly
askew version of what you're talking
about but they were doing that they were
organizing like a thing and then they
had me as like a speaker just come in
and answer some questions and talk to
them about game music and
i think the only other thing i'd add as
well like in terms of like just advice
for anyone who wants to like if you're
you know one against the games industry
and go to all these events the biggest
biggest advice and this has definitely
come up a couple of times this week
everyone in
most people in in the industry want to
talk to people and talk to like new
people coming into the industry but
walk up to someone and strike up a
conversation don't immediately try and
sell them something don't pitch them
because it does happens a lot like with
you'll see like younger people or people
new to the industry who will like be
walking into a group a group of like
friends who've not seen each other for a
couple of years and just be like hey i'm
making this
you know i'm trying to actually you know
i've been pitched almost everything this
week so i don't really use i don't make
any song because it'll sound like i
thought that's something
but like here's my products that i want
to sell and it's like no just hang out
just like get get to know people and as
as austin says like if you treat it as
an opportunity to make friends with
other nerds who share your interests
it's awesome and eventually you know it
will lead to a kind of work and
opportunities but if you treat it as
like a very machiavellian kind of i'm
here to sell this thing people will pick
up on it immediately and and you won't
get invited to the cool boys the mistake
that you the press make um that i've
seen really commonly and it means no one
ever wants to work with you is new press
come in to press events and talk to
other press and just immediately go i
know more than you i know more than all
of you and it's so common that they walk
in and they're like i thought his ruby
was really bad for this reason and we're
like why aren't you talking about that
right now um and they're very aggressive
about it because they think that it will
give them respect i've seen that that's
like the real time this trip i've seen
someone i've seen two jokers talking one
that go to the other and say exactly
yeah i didn't like your piece on this
it's like
doesn't make people like you like you
can think that but it's not networking
and it's like this ego they come in with
and they're like i can do this better
and that's why i should work with you
and everyone's like no thank you has it
ever once like where does a pattern like
that even begin was there this one
famous instance of somebody going your
reviews sucked and they go snacking
it's all about pick up pastry a big
party [ __ ] yeah well i think it's
also that the people doing it aren't
even necessarily doing it as a strategy
they just genuinely think that they're
better than everyone
i've met so many young filmmakers and
game designers but i see it far more in
film for some reason i don't know what
that is um but you can't make a game
with as few people as you can make a
film oh you think it's easier to like
done in kruger your way through a film
than it is i don't know it may be yeah i
just remember the most arrogant
directors i've ever worked with who were
real annoying were the student directors
like i've done a wide gamut of people at
very different places in their career
like some who have achieved a lot and
they have nothing to prove to anybody
and they're like the most ego list the
most how do we make it good and then i
but i remember once there was one
student in particular who you know it
was like his four-minute short film that
he was doing as a class assignment of
undergrad and
um he was you know meeting
we were meeting to see if he wanted to
hire me for his day i was also a student
um
and he was like it's important you
realize the stakes are high on this you
know this this is this is like the
calling card to the word hollywood now
you know
because you know we can't [ __ ] this up
and you can [ __ ] this this is my this is
i don't think you realize how big a deal
this is for me like it was like i was
like you're like a cartoon character
dude this is i couldn't believe it of
course this film was [ __ ] and it's
because people are taught to be like
hustlers like people think that that's
how you impress people is by like
appearing like a big ego like it's we've
had this conversation on the show before
where it's partly that they don't know
enough to know how much they don't know
and i think that i was really arrogant
as a teenager and then i learned that i
didn't know [ __ ] and it's just
unfortunate that that sounds like
someone who's older than a teenager that
you like figure out and you get humbled
by the real world experiences by your
own mistakes but from the start like a
lot of people just walk through and go i
know everything i'm good you see it a
lot with composers because there's a
there's a very and i have a lot of
empathy for this because there's no easy
there's not really a fix to this it's
it's just a nature of the beast where
because
a lot of people grow up
like okay if you take a wide swath of
the population some pretty small subset
gets pretty serious with like playing an
instrument as a kid right so it's not
going to be the majority of people it's
probably a pretty small minority
actually a much much smaller minority of
that group are the ones that go you know
i could write the music and so what
typically happens especially you see it
when la is this
aggregator that pulls people in from all
over the world right a lot of people
there's it's always like this mythical
unicorn to meet an angelino who like
grew up there yeah they're very
especially if they're in the industry
because then people it's very rare that
they would also then pursue because it's
like
it's like you never you're never a
tourist at the cool stuff in your
hometown yeah it's the same thing they
grow up around the business they're
excited to do something different
typically or like they're there because
their parents were in the business and
they're like yeah every now and again
but yeah so point being
the result of which is that most
composers
out in the world like in my case growing
up in denver on the south side in the
suburbs like i was the only composer
that i ever met until i went to school
but i was the only composer that anyone
i knew had ever met and that's normal
the result of which is that everyone
thinks you're super special ingenious
because they're like you actually write
i mean you're basically mozart like
because they have zero and you come out
to la and you realize
i'm actually a dime a dozen all of a
sudden and i'm nowhere like there's i
can name a hundred people more talented
than me and all that kind of stuff
that's the advice
it's the advice i give to students is
like it's not like because obviously now
you've got a lot of games talent comes
through the school system it's like it's
you anyone who's working in games was
the best in their in their secondary
school was probably slash only uh
probably was in the top one or two at
their uni you know you're all those
people are like overachievers but then
yeah once you're actually in the
marketplace it's a big fish
that's why i'm empathetic to the idea
that like there's no justification for
being arrogant like you should learn
elsewhere that it's not good to be that
way like just that's a parallel lesson
in life but i weirdly do understand how
people get convinced because their
parents and their grandparents and their
friends
over there the evidence is there that
they're the best right in the context of
their their upbringing they've been the
best their whole lives it's a rude
awakening sometimes
for sure they're not used to they're not
used to
anything other than like shattering the
non-existent competition
and so it's like i get that i get i get
where they pick up this bad behavior the
the what separates the ones that end up
doing really well is how fast they shed
that yeah and realize
oh [ __ ] i'm actually nobody yeah
yeah i'm being okay with that because
some people get defensive when they
figure that out yeah i know a guy who's
a youtuber who came from a small town
and started youtube when he was really
young and as a result of that
everybody knew him as the youtuber from
our town and so he blew up and so he was
famous in his hometown just everybody
knew who he was uh and it turned him
into a monster in my opinion like not
gonna name the person but like the way
that he
treats people is very much like yeah i'm
not really used to people telling me
anything i say is wrong yeah it's like
very clear that he's like that it's like
i guess when you're 15 and your whole
town thinks you're famous like that's
gonna do some weird [ __ ] to you yeah
yeah and so it's always such a
that's why i like meeting
it's the it's my favorite aspect of
meeting genuinely famous people because
they're
like it makes you first there's so many
reality checks that come flooding at you
really quickly like if it's someone
that's
truly like on a level that like
hollywood super like celebrity kind of
level
um
that's usually a good like pitch of
that's not a very fun life i suspect
because you get the sense that they they
don't people start looking like human
beings to them it's always just what do
you want from me you want something
what's your pitch like they're not
expecting a real moment half the time
and i feel bad for like they've been
they've been you know
there's a lot of rewards that come for
that but this if you're at all
interested in human connection that's
kind of the first sacrifice but then
there's also the people that we think
are famous you know the meeting like the
the the you know like
trying to think of a good example that
doesn't just sound like i'm like
yeah like people who would be the really
really really well known like the
trucker
can walk down the street in l.a and he
will not be bothered presumably but my
point is when someone like us or at
least
when i meet someone like that what i
find is yeah it's
it's always been a very positive
like yeah they they they're they're
really not fundamentally different
they've they've done really well but
they're preoccupied with the same thing
so you realize
you know the arrogance most of them
don't tend to have that there's always
exceptions i've met two or three we've
talked about it often we've recorded it
i'm not of course not i wouldn't be
surprised if they line up but it's not
it's not many i think the industry is
again i feel like because games
especially like if you're a kojima or
you're a druckman requires so many
people to be
just as good as you are at being a
director you have to be a collaborator
you have to and you have to respect that
this person on this team knows more than
you do about this thing yeah you're the
director but they still have to tell you
how it works i genuinely think like if a
member of the audience like who'd never
been around like the games industry in a
literal sense like just wandered into
the lobby downstairs and saw like just
how normal all these famous people are
it's so funny it's walking down there
and then walking past a bunch of people
i know who are just chilling having
drinks just saying like right now
they're all doing it like
we met down there everyone's just
sitting at that bar drinking just having
conversations about the tv shows they
watch yeah and then you're like yeah so
this dude directed this game yeah
yeah it is very very it's not like i
think that's yeah i think i think the
you know and especially in nerd culture
as well because it is that weird thing
that you're pointing at austin where
it's like these people are like internet
famous and like games world famous but
they're just like people just like
normal it's a false fame like yeah it's
just if we identify fame as like the
celebrity type thing if that's like
true fame it's all by degrees i'm
obviously i'm not trying to make a you
know straw man kind of thing but
but um
it's famous it's like twitter famous
more than anything else you know it's
it's it's a lot of what happens on
twitter is not real
nonsense yeah it's like you can't ask an
actual famous person out to dinner
because it proposes a security risk to
the restaurant because they will get
mobbed and they don't necessarily have
the infrastructure to handle that that's
an actual famous person yeah i i
actually i i again i will not
indulge in names but a friend of mine
was a tutor
for the kids of some pretty famous
like movie stars
and one of them was it was a kid who um
because of his life
he had a hard time making friends
so
when my buddy decided to go to a
restaurant for his birthday he asked his
kid like do you want to you want to just
come and hang with me and my friends the
kid was overjoyed you know so he's like
10 years or more it's like i mean he's
like a teenager he's
substantially younger than the rest of
us just chilling talking we're all
talking about video games
nothing you wouldn't know if i hadn't if
you hadn't kind of told me in advance
like just as a heads up you'll see
there's like a bodyguard that will lurk
along the edge of the room to keep an
eye and there was one moment where
somebody like went set and this guy
appeared and was like everything cool
and then immediately disappeared again
wow and it was and i didn't know it was
sounds like the kid of uh you're gonna
have to tell us
like about big names it's just someone
who's yeah like like yeah incredibly
famous parents and
and um and the kid was
very
normal with the asterisks of like you
could feel that this was a rare event
for him and he is
it's sad isn't it there's a sad kind of
loneliness to that life because you're
so
you've got all of the stuff you're
talking about of kind of the everyone
wanting something from you what's your
pitch kind of thing
but it's not exactly it's like it's
you're being used to get to the parents
but i also feel like the kids are
millionaires they're always a little bit
[ __ ] up in a way that's true you've
never had to worry about rent they
bought you a house and you were 10. it's
very like they're always like the
sellers yeah my heart doesn't bleed so
much for it it's definitely like
isolating is being isolated is difficult
no matter how famous and rich you are
that's it's not like that's humans need
to talk and the kid didn't ask for that
or yeah absolutely that's exactly what
i'm about to make
like the kid had no agency in this life
uh
sort of being configured for them and
everything is trade-offs always like
that like you said this kid will
probably never have to worry about money
or anything like that um
but there is a cost that comes with that
there's other things to worry about the
money yeah i wasn't even saying it in a
privileged way i just feel like people
who've never had to worry about money to
that extent
just think and speak differently your
brain works they just are different and
it's like they'll say weird [ __ ] like
like this there's one person that i'm
pretty good friends with who has a very
very famous father
and they bought them a house a beautiful
house and and this person doesn't have
to work they can just do whatever
creative projects that they want
and the way that they approach things is
just like do you want to go hiking let's
go tomorrow like well i i walk and i
like just call off what you think that
that's the thing
people can do to go hiking and they're
like yeah let's leave it like five maybe
we could spend a couple of days what
like how do you think jobs work
like it's not their fault they're like
that but i'm always like wow it's it's a
quote i don't remember what from which
is it's so funny though that's the child
of a millionaire yeah there's part of me
that sort of has this like bohemian
streak that thinks wow that's so cool
like how fun like i've talked to people
where they just go i just i decided next
week to go to europe you know or
whatever like that but then there's the
other part of me that
as a freelancer i actually could say yes
to that
like hypothetically because you've
worked your ass off to create the basic
state of that person
yes i'm lucky that financially i suppose
i could randomly take a few days off
i don't mean it from that angle i mean
like i don't have i don't have like a
regimented schedule as a freelancer i
can all days are whatever i make of them
it's up to me to just by the way the
deadline is next month make sure you hit
it how you use the month is up to you
yeah so i could theoretical but there's
also the part of me that's so not
bohemian because like i love working and
i love being in my desk and someone's
like hey you want to take a weekend off
like this is one of these kind of
recurring challenges with angela because
i'm like we could
we could you know have a little getaway
of catalina but i also could write music
yeah and i love that option and it's
it's earnestly hard because i don't want
to be a bad boyfriend and a bad like
partner but i take my laptop with me
everywhere yeah it's hard you know yeah
i don't think i've ever had a weekend
away and not ended up working in some
capacity that's i feel bad for people
that don't experience that you know the
people that have never had to
work in that way they have a hard time
often discovering a passion because some
at some point
i think part of what drives it becoming
a passion is like the the positive
feedback of i need to pay the bills if i
don't do this thing but hey i'm actually
it's turning out i'm actually kind of
good at this thing you start to the
passion is reinforced it's not just an
abstract thing that's there independent
and i better do this because it's a
thing i love like you fall in love with
it more when you get the feedback of it
and they never get to discover like this
this friend i don't know who it is but
if they
if there's nothing in them
right
i'll tell you awesome jimmy spielberg
yeah let me just say um if they never
really
have that drive they'll never luckiest
about is that i love my career and there
are a lot of people who don't care about
their jobs at all i love what i get to
do for a living flip side of that is
that i feel guilty if i ever have a day
where i don't work so like what we're
talking about here is any day where i
don't produce something i feel bad and i
can't get over that i'm like must work
it's not the healthiest that's a
dangerous pattern i'm the same i've been
like for so long yeah yeah it's not it
and i also use i reward myself for being
exhausted
all the time okay so
because i had a hard week and i worked
really hard there was a day this week
that i didn't sleep and i got into vegas
at midnight so that i didn't miss any
work and then woke up early today like
it was a disaster and i'm like i deserve
to go get a massage tomorrow because of
this why can't i just be nice to myself
independent of the suffering but i can't
it has to be like you only deserve good
things if you feel awful yeah and it's
it's a problem with creative fields in
general i think well it's it's nothing
to you for sure yeah yeah we uh
yeah we turned our passionate hobbies
into
our
not only our form of income but also
but also our yeah our objective in life
you know well i mean look at this
podcast it's like hey let's work 80
hours a week or whatever and then you
want to talk about it let's add some
other couple times
it's true yeah it is that was my i know
i've said this before it was my favorite
comment on one of the first episodes
when somebody said this looks like
people that all work in an office
together and then go to the bar after
work but just talking
yeah and i was like what a great like
that is that is accurate that's a
reasonable description
what an awesome
what you know how lucky to not be the
type who's
catharsis at the bar at the end of work
is to go my [ __ ] boss man my [ __ ]
you'll see me one day i'm getting out of
this place you know like i've had real
jobs i'm very very very grateful that i
don't yeah like i yeah it was like that
when i first joined ign the morale was
really low there for a really long time
to the extent that while i was there
one of the meeting rooms you're allowed
to write on the walls and somebody
started a tally for every person who had
left because of working conditions
like the battlestar galactica you'd walk
in there and you'd see another one and
you're like [ __ ] hell because people
were just leaving because they were
underpaid and from miserable with being
treated poorly um and when i first
joined i was so excited to be there and
we had those like after work bar things
where everyone just bitched about work
the whole time and i was like oh no what
have i done and then i became that
person and i felt it happen and i was
like they shifted me into becoming that
person which is like you know you gotta
complain about bad working conditions
but i had to get myself out of that uh
when i started sort of managing people
there where they would come to me and
complain about stuff and be like you
have to have at least tried to fix the
thing before you come and complain about
it and i tried to do that as much as
possible because otherwise someone would
be like this person was mean to me and
i'd be like okay did you say anything to
them like have you tried to do anything
or are you just complaining because the
pulse just gets worse and less and less
and less and it was like it was brutal
to realize when i when i realized i was
doing it that i was like [ __ ] i became
one of those people's [ __ ] about work
all the time and my job rules
it was hot
have you felt this being your first dice
in person as a dev you obviously have
been before and you know everybody but
is there do you feel any change from
people realizing oh you're one of us
officially
whenever i see people in person now that
i'm in depth the
um
shift in comfort is really obvious yeah
so like very cool you're not going to
get quoted
it's not like you were some scoop like
no i mean i had leaked some stuff um but
i always asked people if i could like i
have you know weeks
especially especially like if you're
drinking say you're like and a
journalist comes over you do there is
that moment of like okay like you sober
up with me like okay i know i need to so
that's come down for you that's good
like i wouldn't say people were ever
that good like they should be like that
but it was still like it was like that
getting hammered all my partners i am
like that
karaoke i love it just neutralizes the
alcohol in your system it really does
for me
but you know what literally happened to
me the other night where um someone from
a press outlet like uh like came over
and we were chatting and a partner came
over we were talking about like you know
talking vaguely about about something we
were working on and uh and and the
journalist asked me a question i was
like i
just prose immediately and like
that would be the big show so
i've always had people be very candid in
terms of like yeah i went to karaoke one
time with a bunch of people from
rockstar and i remember like the amount
of shots that they bought us and then
watching them
they sang that post malone song rockstar
because they thought it was funny it was
like these people don't care at all but
they never said a word rockstar is so
good about like lying to my face to
these that doesn't [ __ ] knew it but
they're very good about it the the
difference is
when i was approaching people at dice
not with the intention of getting scoops
or anything like that
i would ask a question about something
and they would be like ah
because they have to even though i
wasn't asking as a journalist now they
just answer
so that's the biggest shift is people
are always really friendly it's not like
i didn't feel like they were friends
already but
the difference now is just a lot more
candid which i totally respect because
you know even even people who are
devs if i get asked about what i'm doing
in sms and they're like
people all the time like what's the
release date and i'm like dude
people know the line and it's i think
there's some more kind of it's a it's an
intrusive thing like um like earlier
when i asked you a question and you were
like my god we'll see no comment yeah
like it's it's just it's a more casual
thing because it's because there's
there's no potential risk that that's
actually like they're not rude
they're like i was just asking yeah
whereas when you say it to another
person who works in dev and they
understand because we've all got all the
things right there's like there are like
five or six things that each of us
cannot say yeah i had a i had a chat
with a guy i had a conversation about
you that i needed to tell you after i
forgot it was scary someone someone
named
this guy was talking with uh there was a
chat i had a guy kind of been passing
earlier i asked him something about it i
don't even remember what i asked him but
i asked him something about something he
was working on
and he was like he started saying he
goes you know
i told a lot of people last night stuff
i probably shouldn't have said
so if it's cool i'm gonna just try to
like hold the line back up yeah and i
was like all good man if i was working
at a different studio not sms or sony in
general who are very private i feel like
i would probably lie to people for fun
like i was scared yeah just to like if i
were working in a studio that was more
casual i would give people a bunch of
different pieces of information like go
off
you know to see what happens what comes
out like that's what because i know that
when i was at ign i had ubisoft
employees which i now respect lie to me
all the time because i'd be like yeah
they said this and then i would say to
someone else and then a month later
you'd be like that didn't [ __ ] happen
like they just lied to me constantly
just to make you go away or to like they
could also be like
i don't think they have trouble with it
i mean i don't think it's that bad
because because at least twice i texted
them and they were like yeah i was
bullshitting okay
which makes the job really difficult to
press but it was also funny that like
it's almost as if people should have
some skepticism they would read in the
press
you know
especially games media it's so
controlled you know like it's it's very
difficult i think it's actually it's
like if it shows how easily that happens
in games media where
the stakes are not
life and death
you know in general then healthy dose of
skepticism it you should have that with
any aim yeah recording really but i
think um like
games media there was a guy that i
worked with who it turned out was a
pathological liar oh that's fine and
that meant that he was giving us
information about games that he heard
from devs that we found out all wasn't
true i'm calling troy he messaged me 40
minutes ago like i'm around where's the
link
hey guys
you're on speakerphone we're literally
recording so just know it's mike is live
yeah how are you doing sorry i totally
didn't realize that like a half an hour
ago you messaged me
oh you okay bud
[Laughter]
um well yeah we're in a room together at
dice and it's wonderful uh we should be
here
there's a photo of us on the wall though
yeah yeah
wait there's a photo
but it's kind of changed a few times
you need to get consistent
is it a law of me
we're at the delano and there are
pictures in all of the hotel rooms
there are multiple of them which i
didn't i only know because you told me
yeah various
people underwater
like presumably
they're just fondling
yeah there's cleavage in mine there's oh
yes yeah my my room i have the butt
version of this which one was the spot
could you send me a picture i would say
you could take that off the wall
one year i compiled
yeah it's a photo
it's i think it's video i think
someone's filmed a video and then
they've basically taken individual
frames and use them in different rooms
because i i one year i got everyone to
take photos of it and we worked out
there about six variants and they're not
particularly high quality or anything
aren't you so glad that i called you so
that they could
explain the art to you he's the audio
listener this time i also love that we
were explaining the art in a video
podcast everyone can see it that's
watching this anyway don't worry your
listeners can't like troy don't care
about the audio
are you uh are you good sir i know that
you obviously are not gonna explain what
you're doing but are you having fun oh
yeah man we're having so much fun we
literally are i've got this is my
uh penultimate
yeah you've been away uh good months now
what have you guys been doing have you
except that it's awesome and it's a lot
of good people and
no at this point i'm definitely in the
nightmare stage yeah like jet laggy is
that is there just knackered just and
the the uh the dryness of the air as
well thanks so much
so much yeah also all the cigarettes
yeah yeah forget i always forget about
that you can smoke inside here okay we
tried
i wish that i was there with you have so
much fun and break a leg
i have no predictions for the awards
it's great
i think you'll probably win yeah you'll
win yeah
all right he's going he hung up
we actually i think we have to leave
yeah
thank you so much for watching sir if
the audio was terrible
you know did our best don't know how
it's gonna sound i keep worrying that
i'm too far and then i thought maybe you
have
actively aware that the audio is going
to be [ __ ] however who cares i tried
to it's the production value that the
audience expects i leaned forward when i
had like substantive things to say and
if i was basically going oh yeah
interesting yeah see the level's like
green when you're back there yellow when
you're here i'm always green
i wish i had been paying attention to
the meter on there i didn't realize that
was there
and this is my volume yes i'm about the
same zone as you as well yep yeah it's
professional it's
okay this is the last episode then we do
that and then for the 10th anniversary
yeah
then here's the lost one it'll be so
amazingly anti-climactic i say we
release it as like a fifty dollar
the whole three people will buy them and
split it would be great um yes austin
and i have to go to rehearsals thank you
everybody for tuning in sorry about the
audio it was worth it to be in person
thanks for 95 episodes
[Music]